what was it with you and John Candy like
John Candy was one of your all-time
favorites yeah when I was like when I
was a kid everybody was talking about
SNL and of course SNL is a huge thing
but my brothers and I we were staying at
my grandfather's house he had this
little cottage in Miss kwamicut Rhode
Island and one night my brothers came
and woke me up and said there's this
thing on TV that's so amazing but it was
like finding a rare Jewel they showed me
SCTV unbelievable unbelievable and it
was so funny and it was the first time I
thought as much as I liked SNL I thought
they're making this for me and John
Candy uh was one of my favorite
performers on that show and they did a
sketch and it was called yellow belly
it's a promo for a TV show again coming
next on SCTV this fall yellow belly and
he plays this coward who was a Cavalry
officer and was a coward so it's John
Candy shaking and a woman and a girl a
little daughter passed by and one of
them says mama is that yellow bell and
she goes yes that's yellow belly and
yellow belly turns around and shoots
them in the back
I didn't think you could do that it is
so wrong and I yellow belly I laughed so
hard the next year
um I wanted John Candy to come at
Harvard yeah and so we got John Candy to
come and I'll never forget I picked him
up and were in the car and I just said
I'm sorry Mr candy but yellow belly he
gets like a big John Candy laugh he goes
yeah that was crazy yeah that's funny
and then we ended up hanging out on what
I remember most clear clearly is he was
everything I wanted him to be he was
John Candy he was over the top
funny all the time called me kid and
what I remember very clearly is I've
been given a list he was supposed to be
on a diet the pritikin diet
we drive and he says kid Let's Take a
Walk I said oh okay Mr candy guy don't
call me you know Mr candy I'm John all
right all right John I'm walking along
next to him and we're drift we're
roaming around Cambridge and the first
thing he does is he sees a pastry shop
and he goes let's go kid and we go into
the pastry shop and he goes I have one
of those one of those one of those one
of those and they start stacking eclairs
all these different eclairs into a box I
think there were three colors and their
second all into a box and he sees me
looking at him and he goes He nudges me
and he goes don't worry kid they're
pretty kind of Claires
and I was like I thought this is he is
this guy yeah and then a lovely thing
happened which is
um I told this to somebody it got back
to someone in their family they were
going through some of their dad's stuff
they found some photographs and her dad
John had taken two photos of me that day
at Harvard
and so they're these pictures of me
looking like an 11 year old girl you
know there at Harvard Yard from 1984.
it's was just miraculous to think wow
John Candy took these photos and had
them in his closet somewhere you know
what was that part where you said you
said to Mr candy I want to try comment
oh yeah try comedy yeah yeah I was I'll
never forget where I was I was in the
Lampoon building and there was a big
party and he was there having fun and we
were standing by a window looking down
on the street and I just said you know
Mr candy I'm really thinking I was
nervous but I because I'm I'm not a you
know I don't think of myself as a brave
person or a reckless person and it's
like I'm gonna really I've worked so
hard and to get to this college and then
now I'm gonna go try this thing that
famously Flames out for most people my
parents are gonna kill me and I said to
him you know Mr Kenny I'm thinking I
might try comedy and he just his head
whipped around he looked me right in the
eye and he said you don't try AI comedy
you do it or you don't do it and that
hit me very powerfully like there's no I
you know and I think that was my
attitude going into it in 85 was you
know I'm not going to take the LSAT I'm
not going to have a backup this just has
this just has to work